first of all congratulations on a great
ending and starting with Jennifer could
you talk about your last moments as
Katniss and for Josh can you talk about
how you did the great job of dual pitas
um I feel like I kind of had to um
final endings with Katniss the one when
I rapped when we wrapped the film in
Berlin and the one which everybody oh my
god um with everybody and you know woody
and Josh and Liam and everyone was there
and I was kind of saying goodbye to the
movie and then I had a last scene about
a year later um with my nephews which
was so special they played my children
in my Odyssey oh sure okay
um they played my children and the scene
that month so it was like this amazing
closure to this character who have loved
for so many years to have my family
they're my blood family instead of this
family I got to say goodbye to both
mm-hm
different times yeah for me it was cool
you know this was like the the final
episode that I was looking forward to
when I read the books you know where
Peter kind of you know is hijacked and
becomes tortured and all these things it
was cool to take a character that has
like such a special place for like the
fans you know take that kind of
character there my love so much is this
golden boy or whatever and then turn
into that dark side and kind of explore
that while also having that like back
and forth kind of a big quasi bipolar
from all the trauma he's experienced
congratulations all of you an amazing
job an amazing journey going along with
all of you for the ride but I want to I
want to ask Francis the total bandwidth
emotionally and visually has been very
important to this franchise from the
very beginning but we see a definitive
shift in this final installment in terms
of more of Katniss coming into her own
and thinking for herself for herself or
the future how did you incorporate that
emotional shift into your visual
dynamics Wow I it's it's funny I don't I
didn't really think about
sort of a shift in visualized visual
dynamics in this movie based on her
character I mean Katniss has always been
the anchor for me she's sort of our eyes
into this world and we're following her
and she's the anchor in every sequence
in every scene and so for me visually
but it's throughout all the movies I'm
sort of anchored to her so were usually
walking into rooms with her and seeing
other people talk from her you know
point of view uh and the big difference
tone alene emotionally really is just
with her journey itself in the movie but
it didn't really affect my my visual
approach at all Jennifer could you
tuckle that go back to that last last
scene when you'd finally wrapped could
you just talk about sort of the ending
the character was a like accomplishment
I've I've done what I can with her was a
little kind of bittersweet that I'm
giving up this character now um I don't
know I think the feeling of
accomplishment probably happened more
when the film finally comes out was you
know we're not really done working on it
in some ways where we stopped to
represent it and um I don't know I
didn't really feel like I said I said
goodbye to her it's it's funny I mean
that's what we do on every movie is we
develop these characters in a few months
later you never see them again um so I
guess I'm used to that so I didn't
really feel it so much character wise at
the end of Hunger Games I think it'll be
pretty bizarre when the movies finally
out we finished this press tour and
everything's officially done I think
that's gonna be a pretty weird feeling
just on a personal level
his movies been my life for so many
years congratulations on the film the
sewer sequence how many days were you
guys did you get spent wet was your
costume at all waterproof and for mr.
Lawrence what was that like shooting
this action scene in such a
claustrophobic environment uh it was
absolutely the most miserable three
weeks
I think in the three selfies it was it
only three weeks it was only three weeks
no I mean it felt like I felt like nine
weeks but it was about three weeks it
was it was really true truly miserable
uh it's it's kind of a fun sequence to
make in a sense and to sort of put
together and see how it comes together
but you know these tunnels you had to
duck if we all had to wear hardhats the
water was heated so it would made
everything orally it is stand up
straight for three yeah it made it hated
human smoky yeah it was wet it was
miserable everybody was miserable and
the thing is like the costumes were not
at all water no they're not at all they
had pockets though it actually don't
really fill with boiled water but it was
when we get to the fight sequence sorry
we're all just like complaining I had a
ball we're very lucky but when we had
the fight sequence in the sewer you know
all of our gear and our costumes were
completely waterlogged so it was like an
extra 20 pounds
I don't know math but felt like an extra
2,000 I don't own pound yeah it was hard
as rough it so organized yeah but
it'sit's actually interesting because
it's something they don't really teach
you in film school that when you get to
a certain point and you're you know
seven months into you know an 11-month
shoot and you hit a sequence like this
and the mood and morale of the crew and
the cast hits a rock bottom
what is what it's like psychologically
to sort of push through those kinds of
things those kinds of experiences to get
what you need and you know it was on
time is on schedule although it was just
truly miserable um yeah but I'm really
happy with the results I really into the
night forgetting the pain yeah it was
just at the end of that sequence it was
just like oh my god we have more shots
to do that good because that final that
final room it felt like it was just
never-ending
yeah however I like right here belfodil
enews um my questions for Jennifer first
great job by everyone on great film
loved it um I think you're acting
Jennifer in this film your range shows
that you're on your way to a Meryl
Streep in career and
and I just want to say that your
performance in this film in this series
cements Katniss Everdeen as an iconic
figure like Indiana Jones and Rocky
Balboa I know I have a friend of teen
friend of mine her mother mom and dad
both have cancer and she still lights up
when she's looking forward to new Hunger
Games Movies and she's like Oh Katniss
would still smile Katniss wouldn't give
up so you do have an impact we're in
that way so I guess my question just is
um you know this has had such an impact
and these movies have been so successful
on Catching Fire I believe was the first
female led movie we never went the box
office since 1969 and has helped other
female movies get made so with that I
mean what do you feel do you feel the
impact of this character and be since we
always look toward the future under
Zoomers that what was Judy has really
wants you to be there Captain Marvel
would you ever want to do that combined
you know playing that sandbox or Bradley
and Chris Pratt and all of those people
I would love to play in a sandbox with
them first of all thank you that's the
nicest thing I've ever heard of my life
thank you um I I feel the impact of
being a part of such a huge movie that
does so much for so many people I mean
it would be impossible not to and I
think that this character is so
overwhelmingly supportive of women
obviously and um and is iconic I don't
feel a personal empathic I have an in it
I think that if you ever become aware of
that then it kind of takes away from it
a little bit so it's just kind of it's
the movie and the characters and they
kind of have their own life and
it's kind of like your avatar self I
don't know and yes Liam um two-part
questions say do you feel bit down or
sad because you didn't get the girl at
the end and also and also what do you
think about the evolution of your
character because now Gale Gale has
turns just somebody who's kind of
cold-hearted like thinking a collateral
damages in war you know it happens so
those are my questions yeah I don't I
don't feel down I actually feel pretty
happy no I mean you know obviously I
read the books too so I always knew that
that was going to happen at the end um
you did question it though yeah yeah and
rehearsal energy going took like I don't
get it right away what's so bad about
him he's a good guy apart from all the
killing and stuff um yeah he gets pretty
angry towards the end you know he's been
through a lot know for a long time you
know I really didn't have any any power
to do anything and you know through this
last part he's front and center and and
is able to really make an impact and I
think it all kind of goes to his head a
little bit and he loses sight of his own
morals and values and that's kind of why
you know Carolyn Gale and Katniss sort
of part ways I guess you know they have
a strong disagreement about what's right
anymore and that's something that in the
end Katniss can't really let go I you
guys look great by the way you know the
Hunger Games series is originally for
young adults and a lot of them look up
to you as people and your characters in
the movie what do you hope that young
people will take away from this film I
mean for me a message is always
resonated that that I think is pretty
strong is about standing up where you
believe in and how one person has the
ability
affect something you know that one
person can stand up and and get behind a
cause or what they believe in and fight
for it so I think that those are are
pretty pretty strong messages that I
hope that fans take I think they have I
think it's why they connected with in a
way because it empowered them and and it
gave them a sense of empowerment
that's what empowering means so yes I
think that for me like that that's
something I really hope people take away
from me and the consequence of war
obviously you know I think can is a
character who wants nothing more than to
not have war but unfortunately I think
in the last you know finale of the film
she kind of realized that's where it's
headed and that's what has to be done in
order to have a revolution well I do
think that the notion of social change
and the possibility that you know
defiance in the face of injustice and
kindness in the face of cruelty that I
think young people I think that these
sort of popularity of you know dystopic
fiction speaks to an anxiety that young
people feel about the future that awaits
them and what I find so hopeful in these
books and in these movies is the fact
that you can create change and that you
can refuse to play the game and see your
world change as a result and I think
that also the voice of young women and
their power to change the world and
their world and be a spokesperson for
that kind of change has been something
that certainly Jen has been risen to the
occasion of and they hope young people
whether they're boys or girls will rise
to that occasion and change the world
because we need to do that I
congratulations I think it's a very
satisfying ending now
another lifetime if they're remaking
Mockingjay what other part would you
play that you maybe admired throughout
the filmmaking I mean I've always loved
image but Woody's perfect so I don't
know
snow be snow be kind of cool too we had
the top payment yeah yeah there wouldn't
be a topping he is that guy yeah
apart from he's not a drunk alcoholic
yeah yeah no no no no I just mean his
his loving sense of humor yeah yeah
probably Haymitch this questions for the
producer and Jennifer I was already food
this one is already set for release in
China because last time we didn't it
delayed it and I did Jennifer didn't get
to go I was wondering if this time you
can go to Beijing what do you expect
there do you want to try some like a
traditional Chinese food or some
experience well we were all really
disappointed last time we were excited
to go and you know we had such an
incredible experience the fans of this
franchise I've been thinking about it a
lot and talking to people about it you
know often times when something is
beloved it provokes haters somehow but
is like those two things have to live
alongside each other especially in the
era of you know kind of all the internet
chatter and we've been very lucky then
that we don't have the haters we have
incredibly supportive smart passionate
inspired fanbase and we haven't gotten
the chance to experience that in China
yet and it's a place I've you know to
get to go and interact with the fans
there and to get to see this movie have
a life there that we get a chance to
witness this time is something I think
we're all really excited about my hello
my questions my questions for Jennifer
the your character choose stop fighting
actually it's kind of piece game so and
she go back to hometown and make a
family and more like a peaceful and
ordinary people's lifestyle she choose
but Gale did not
so how effect you yourself you know the
are in the future you're kind of
thinking to going back home to more like
a peaceful life and something work to
come back to the Hollywood or you stay
more like a Tinseltown you can live stay
there and making family or more like
ordinary people lifestyle you kind of
think that way I think there's a we all
have had to find a balance and feeling
ordinary in our lives that are you know
bizarre and finding a home and you know
we're in a place where we weren't born I
I don't really feel like as escaping
from anything you know when I when I
finish a movie I still like to stay in
New York or LA and I enjoy working I
don't I don't really feel there's
certain things that I that I'd like to
that I like to escape from in this
business but for the most part I don't I
don't really feel like like going up I'm
like going off into the country if I was
like someplace quiet I would I would
just like lose my mind I'm sure one day
I will and I want to retire and slow
down but as of now I really I love
working I love being busy I love reading
or writing or doing anything to keep
myself busy hi I'm Nina you talked about
social change and young women speaking
up and using their voices and Jennifer I
know you just wrote a Lenny letter about
not making as much as your male co-stars
um and I wonder if you would talk a
little bit about what prompted you to
write that and and why you did that um I
I would love to like straighten up that
I wasn't I wasn't writing about not I
mean yes I did not make as much as my
male co-stars was it wasn't so much as a
complaining about you know I wasn't
getting paid more because I'm a woman it
was more of how did my mentality get in
my own way
of you know fighting just as hard as the
men to get a better deal is that because
I'm a woman as the only point of view I
have is from a woman's point of view and
so I you know there definitely wasn't
any foul play involved you know on
Sony's part they're not going to give
somebody more money if they don't ask
for it no foul play from the men or
anybody making that movie a lot of you
know things have to be rearranged and
exceptions have to be made when you're
going to have that many movie stars in
one movie I hoped to just write kind of
more about how my own fears of how am I
going to be portrayed or how am I going
to look or how will people judge me got
in my way when you know obviously the
men in the movie don't don't think that
way and you know even after writing it
there's still you know it's been called
and I don't remember what website it was
but like called it Jennifer Lawrence's
bratty display and I was like thank you
for completely making my point that if a
woman goes you know and speaks up and is
assertive and has a voice you know she's
going to be called a brat or gonna be
caught you know I just don't see a man
being called a brat but um
mmm mommy but if you're bar-abba i think
i think that when people say oh well you
know what does this role mean for young
women you know I think that the way that
what Jen spoke about which I found
really powerful as a woman I completely
relate to is that you know you don't
always want or feel entitled to be the
spokesperson as a woman and I just
recently did a workshop that was
sponsored by women in film has Sundance
about you know really getting to the
50-50 place of gender parity that we
ought to be at behind in front of the
camera and in the checkbook and that
applies to so many women you know who
don't have the profile and the ability
to have a public forum but oftentimes
you know even coming out of Sundance
let's say where it'll be half and half
of women directors coming out of the
program and then you look to a couple
years later who's working and it's like
3% of the women
who came out of the winning category or
working and 97% of the men of the people
who are still working after Sundance and
so obviously a lot of that is chauvinism
but also as girls we don't always have
the confidence to feel like we're going
to that we won't be judged if we speak
up and I think that that is really what
was at the heart of that essay and I
think it's something resonates with
Katniss at the character we sort of
forced to speak up and I think it's a
really important yeah two questions the
first one for Jennifer was that you
singing on the the closing soundtrack
that first song that we heard and if so
was that as a result of the success of
the single that was released from the
last film and the second question would
be for Nina and Francis and that is when
Haymitch was reading the goodbye letter
from philip Seymour Hoffman's character
I it got me very emotional because I
realized that he was no longer with us
and I was wondering if that letter was
part of the concessions that needed to
be made in order to keep the plot going
because he was no longer there to film
his scenes yes Phil was supposed to be
in that scene with Katniss and so that
was one of the the big changes that was
one of his big scenes that he had not
completed when he died and so that was
our change because of that event and
before she talks I mean having Jen sing
the the lullaby at the end had nothing
to do with the success of the hanging
tree and had an entirely to do with the
idea of Katniss at the end of the movie
singing the same song to her child that
she's saying to prim at the in the very
first scene of the series so it was
about sort of seeing that that
connection with with family and with
child well Jennifer I have to tell you I
don't think you're a brat at all and I
don't think most people in this room see
you or view you when you express
yourself observing your career and you
move through it with such style and
grace but you didn't have come
but you do it just by being yourself I
mean and and that shocks the crap out of
most people that hear you speak publicly
so I was wondering if you might describe
the trajectory or the ride the last five
years have been the best parts and
they're not so much I mean it's a hard
thing to sum up really honestly it's
it's it's a job I really love acting
I really do I so I really just I really
just think of myself as just like a
working woman and I and I just go from
set to set and work and then you know
you have to promote a movie you have to
work people are going to have opinions
and tah you know it's it's it's it's
weirdly very easy to kind of block out
the world because you have your own so I
guess with the five years with ups and
down you know there's there's there was
a few years of getting used to it your
entire world changes and as far as like
now it's very easy for me because I'm
isolated I am I have a new normal now
and so I feel very stable and normal and
happy and but it took a few years to to
get used to being looked at differently
is kind of a very alienating feeling
because you don't feel different and
everybody reacts to you differently but
the the pressure you just can't think
about it it'll just it'll just just keep
you up so I don't know I guess it was
just a few years of getting used to it
and then I got used to it and then I was
like okay let's get back to work and
then people react and can do whatever
they want but that's fine that's on them
I'm just I just have a job that's how I
think of it I'm I'm sorry if I'm not
answering anybody's questions I think
you've answered every question really
yes thank you
you're not listening
and don't lie you've been zoning out all
completely all I can think about the
squeaky Jim in Mordor yeah oh yeah
that's what that is yes hmm hey Jen
Jennifer sorry
hey Jen um actually for all you guys how
do you how looking back I mean you said
that this movie has been your life for
years and years now looking back how do
you three think that you've changed or
grown professionally or personally over
these past several years it's hard to
say it's probably still too soon to be
able to look back and and reflect um
I hope I've grown up I I mean it's much
easier to be mature on sets without Josh
and Liam I'm sure I'm unrecognizable to
people I'm working with um I don't know
getting it we all helped each other get
a handle on everything um so I guess
kind of going off and not doing movies
with them was kind of like losing
training wheels and then it's like okay
okay I can ride them in the street okay
I can do it I know for me it's like
always a hard question like anytime
anybody asks like what have you learned
I don't know if I just don't learn
anything ever or I don't know because I
feel like I'm constantly learning things
just in life and experience with working
with various actors and directors and
everything that's the one it this one's
got to go whose office um because like I
don't really I don't remember like okay
today I learned this like I don't I
don't reflect upon I kind of just grow
and as a person and and like I mean for
us it was it was like I mean for me
really was I got college experience in
many ways but you know it was education
yeah exactly so I didn't learn anything
at all
SoDo I mean I I know I've learned many
things and I've grown a lot as an actor
as a person everything but to really say
like something specific I don't know
yeah I think sort of getting used to
like your world constantly changing
that's not going from one extreme to the
other or something over the past six
years it is I think it gets easier you
know I think at first as a young person
doing something like this and going from
one extreme situation to another is
really overwhelming yeah over over years
you learn to sort of I think let it go
and and and not be so attached to having
a routine or you know feeling safe at
all I think you just have to let go that
thing yeah just like I would say you're
just accepting that you're you know you
got to just go with Rowling's well yeah
because our jobs are so is so full-on I
always say like if you're working it's
you know 13 to 16 hour days every single
day in a strange city where you don't
know anybody you don't know your
surroundings you don't know anyone and
then you wrap and you've got time off
which is great but then you just go to
nothing and if I'm an alcoholic
it's hard because you it's hard to find
not me I'm just talking about friends
I'm speaking objectively but yeah it's
hard to find a balance because you're we
go from being overworked me like oh my
god I need time off I'm so exhausted my
body and then you get time off and your
mind is going crazy because I hate
waking up without a goal and going to
sleep without achieving nothing so it's
so I you know just start out minded
someone's you have to say so now we just
obsessively work on weekends I meet with
directors and pitch myself is for
Francis but I want all three two actors
to respond as well when you first
started with the first installment of
this franchise I'm pretty sure you had
seen second okay okay the second one
sign I'm pretty sure you had a direction
in mind and you had some kind of control
over that direction however with the
success and all the craziness that goes
with that was it hard to maintain that
original direction and as far as the
actors the same thing here did studios
pressure you to do the characters any
different not at its successful and they
know it's making money or did they just
let you guys just continue the mission
that you started with now I think I
think the you know my objectives you
know I was able to see them through it I
came in and I met with Nina for the
first time
I was hired about a week later and I had
a very clear idea of the way that I
wanted to tell the story and luckily
Nina really agreed and the studio really
agreed and everybody kind of kept their
word and when I was hired I then went
and kind of pitched my approach to all
the actors that were already part of it
um and everybody was kind of on board
which was an amazing thing there were
there were no fights and it never
changed throughout I think everybody
everybody was on the same they were all
we were all in the same car yeah I don't
I don't think so I mean I don't think
that the success at all impacts your
depiction of the character I mean you
know it's all in the books you know like
the characters are there and and you're
gonna play them how you see them and and
so I don't think the success at all
there's no pressure on the studio like
you need to be funnier now that we were
making money yeah there's nothing that
doesn't change and develop we try to
grow with our characters our characters
were growing so certain things would we
would change with them but Lionsgate is
an incredibly supportive studio and also
Francis came in with a brilliant idea
and does a brilliant job and so I don't
even think there was me it's not really
anything to say he's Francis is an
amazing director he's fantastic it's no
one better to work with in Francis he's
just he's awesome I agree him though
here here help Thank You Lenahan my I
said it to sort my questions for Francis
the story gets so chaotic at times and
so crazy and it feels very wartime asked
about the movie but that sewer scene
could have been too much at times but it
was so controlled especially leading up
to the conclusion with finish what was
your direction in order to make sure
that you made the audience feel
terrified but also made sure that they
understood what was happening still well
there's a couple things I think that you
know I always try to apply a specific
emotional value to a sequence and so
obviously this was an opportunity to be
really terrifying which was that part of
it was really fun I mean the actual
physical process of making it sucked but
that was fun and so the sort of design
of the ancestor of the sort of
suspenseful first act of that sequence
was where I thought the real scares were
but in terms of making sure that we
understood what was going on I worked
really closely with the stunt stunt team
the stunt choreographer coordinator in
designing the fight and figuring out how
to cover the fight where we could hold
for long periods of time so that we
could maintain the sense of geography so
we sort of knew where all the actors
were the characters were at any given
time and understood what was happening
and what they were doing and who was in
peril and what they were feeling and so
we let things play out it made it really
complicated and it made it much more
difficult what which is why it took so
long because we didn't have the room
anymore to sort of hide things in messy
and sloppy camerawork but I think it was
really useful in the sequence her on
mamo daily Trojan for us see first of
all great film loved it cried about four
times my question is for Jennifer in the
movie Katniss Everdeen has become this
household name that symbolizes courage
and strength in the midst of the
rebellion two viewers today in present
time what you think Katniss Everdeen
symbolizes hopefully this hopefully the
same ideals
you know audiences are growing up with
this character um so I don't know I hope
that there everybody's going to take
away something different with each film
and as they as they get older I'm so bad
at answering questions but um I have a
really I really know what I'm trying to
say um I don't know I mean I hope that
they take away the same thing as as they
always have but also our audience will
grow and and you know learn more see
more of themselves or see more of what
they want from from this world of this
country
although this question is for Jennifer
just regarding franchise franchise films
we often see how actors struggle
afterwards to see success in their
professional in their profession field
so I'm just wondering seeing out now I'm
struggling just like you so I'm just
wondering we haven't seen that with you
because you just keep filming and
filming and other and their success is
just blooming so why do you think that
it or another my question is just what
why do you think that is um wife and I'm
incredibly a damn good actress think
honey I've been really fortunate um well
you know when I when I shot the first
Hunger Games movie and then I am I
auditioned for David O'Russell for
silver linings about two weeks after I
rapped so he had no idea you know what
was about to happen
um so I I remember you know there have
been a few times where I would have
really loved time off but I was very
aware of how overwhelming these movies
in this character was and that was a big
fear of mine signing on to the movies um
I don't want I want every people to be
able to lose themselves when they're
when they're watching a movie not see a
see you know kind of the same character
this character however is remarkable and
in my opinion the greatest I think she's
the greatest female character ever so I
wasn't you know too mad at that but I
just tried to just I just tried to keep
working so that people could see other
characters other things that I could do
instead of taking vacation time and now
I'm aging like a president but it's
worth it
you